Georgia Governor Brian camp is suing the
Atlanta City Council and mayor Keisha
atlantes bottoms to block the city's
mass mandate the suit claims the mayor
overstepped her authority after Kemp
issued an executive order Wednesday
explicitly barring local governments
from announcing mask requirements there
are at least 15 local governments in
Georgia that have mandated face
coverings America Atlanta bottoms joins
us now from Atlanta she's been under
quarantine at home after announcing she
tested positive for the virus
earlier this month mayor bottoms good
morning to you I want to jump right into
this because your state is in the middle
of a fight against a deadly virus and
now also a fight between the governor
and yourself what's going on here it's
really odd that the governor has filed
this lawsuit on July 1st the city of
Savannah through mayor Johnson
instituted a mask order on July 8th the
governor's hometown of Athens Georgia
instituted a mask order but it was not
until we instituted a mask order in
Atlanta and I pointed out that Donald
Trump violated that order when he landed
at our Airport and did not wear masks
that the governor filed suit against us
and so it is very clearly that it's very
clear that the governor is putting
politics over people and I joined
several mayor's across our state who
will continue to enforce our masks
mandate and we will have to fight the
governor about this in court
are you saying that President Trump
encouraged governor Kemp to issue this
lawsuit I can't speak to whatever
conversations that they had but I do
know that our governor is a trump law
olace and he seems to work very hard to
police the President of the United
States and that is often at the expense
of the people in our state and we've
seen that this is the same governor who
said in the midst of this pandemic that
he had just learned that this virus
could be transmitted by asymptomatic
transmission and so even when he
reopened the state interestingly enough
he did not have the support of the
President
then but certainly many of his policies
are a lot step with the White House so
but mayor governor Kemp has come around
that he now says he quotes strongly
encourages residents to wear masks why
do you have to go a step further and
make them mandatory I can't speak to
that because many of the governor's
decisions as it relates to their logical
but mayor bottom is what I'm asking is
why do you need to go a step further to
make masks mandatory when the governor
is already encouraging them well the
reason that we need to go a step further
is because we need some consistency
throughout our city we have very high
numbers in the city of Atlanta and we
have business owners who are saying that
it would be helpful to them if there
were consistency throughout the city and
quite frankly it's very simple wearing a
mask helped stop the spread of this
virus and so we will continue to do
everything that we can do to make sure
that people are safe but ironically even
in this lawsuit of challenging our mask
mandate
he's also challenging advisory voluntary
recommendations that he had made to
businesses in terms of reverting back to
phase one yeah he says you're confusing
people he also says that the mask
mandate is unenforceable you just said
President Trump arrived and violate the
mandate how will you enforce it and will
you pursue that enforcement against the
President himself well the way that we
will enforce it is the way that we would
import any city ordinances any city
ordinance you can issue a citation you
can give people a fine but and I'm not
going to cite the President of the
United not to point out that he well one
he's not here now so we can't give him a
ticket if he's not in Atlanta but it was
to point out that he was violating the
rules of our city and just a blatant
disregard for the science right in our
backyard we have the CDC we have Emory
University that said wearing
a mask will help stop the spread of this
virus and yet governor Kemp went to a
small university and I state to get the
opinion that he wanted I think you could
probably locate the president if you
wanted to hand him that citation but I'm
curious about the perspective of
businesses the governor says he's
bringing this lawsuit on behalf of
businesses and people who are looking
for jobs want to stay employed what's
your response to that do you think the
mandatory mask requirement and your
rollback to phase one hurts the economy
there in Georgia absolutely not again
Reading Is Fundamental are
recommendations going back to phase one
were advisory voluntary recommendations
and so to be sued based upon the issuing
voluntary advisory recommendations
really is just a waste of taxpayer money
in our state we don't have appropriate
contact tracing we don't have adequate
testing in our state I personally waited
eight days for results and by the time I
got my results when we I was tested it
was one person in my household who was
asymptomatic and positive eight days
later myself and my husband were then
yeah positive for Kovac 19 and my
husband being very ill so I think a
better use of taxpayer money would be to
expand testing and contact tracing in
our state and not to waste it on suing
me personally in our Atlanta City
Council personally simply because we're
trying to save lives in our city do you
think the governor's positions is
costing lives I absolutely think that
it's costing you think the governor's
position is killing people there in
Georgia that's a pretty bow
we have over 31 we have over 3,100
Georgians who have died of kovat 19 I
believe our numbers as of yesterday were
over 130,000 who have tested positive
many are senior citizens many are in
minority communities and so I think that
when you are reckless as the governor
has been when you disregard science as
the governor has done then certainly
people are suffering and people are
dying
in our state and our numbers are rising
at a record rate all right mayor Keesha
Lance bottoms thank you for being with
us we wish the best of health to you and
your family